- He loves music and singing.
- He does, is that what it says in there?
- [Woman] No.
- [Man] Because it should.
(upbeat music)
- A lot of people have their
own opinion of what he is.
- I've always said she's
got some Beagle in her.
- Maybe some type of pit bull?
- I know he's mostly
terrier, or I think he is.
- She's probably a Dachshund mix.
- Maybe a hound or something in there?
- They said that he's a
Schnauzer because he has a beard.
- There could be terrier in there,
I wouldn't be surprised.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Alright, obtain cheek cells.
Sit!
Oh, that's a good boy!
- Okay, sit still.
She'll just eat it.
- [Voiceover] What's
this puppy, what is this?
Let me see your mouth.
- There we go buddy.
- Yeah, rah rah rah!
- See!
Chihuahua, Miniature Poodle,
Cocker Spaniel, what!
- Contragulations, he's an American Staff.
- [Voiceover] Oh, he's--
- He's the king dog!
- You're the king of the pit bulls!
- Bell is Chihuahua, American
Staffordshire Terrier,
and Cocker Spaniel.
- That is the weirdest combination.
You don't look like any of those things.
- You're a weirdo.
- How crazy, oh, Jim!
That explains so much.
- So one of her parents was Chihuahua,
Staffordshire Terrier,
and the other one was
Chihuahua, Cocker Spaniel--
- [Man] Mix.
- Unknown third breed mix.
And there's no Dachshund in her at all.
- [Man] No.
- So he's all American Staff.
- Like his parents.
And grandparents, and
then this little ink blot
on his resume.
- [Man] Seriously.
That is very cool.
- Black dogs aren't usually adopted
but he was really cute, I loved him
and I wanted him so I just got him.
I love him, like that's my best friend.
- Someone was just like,
I found this dog on the street,
who wants to take it?
- [Man] Yeah.
- And then we were like,
oh, we'll take her.
- We had talked about a lot
of the discrimination against pit bulls.
You know, we weren't gonna go buy a dog
or even look for a pure pit bull,
it was more just about rescuing
and more just about the dog's personality.
- I don't think a breed of a dog
would ever make or break
an adoption for me.
- No.
- It doesn't matter what breed it is,
it's just love.